suitory to break down so Charlie
Burnett's should I get some brief screen
time where it's revealed that she has a
yellow lightsaber their then gritty
fight sequences that flushed on the
screen as eight Jedi is showing taking
their lightsabers out while overlooking
an unknown sight and I gotta say it from
the footage I saw in the trailer the
production quality of this looks
absolutely amazing it looks like a HBO
show and it just looked really well made
like and or because production crawling
on that was fantastic and the fight
scenes like that martial arts sequence
just looked absolutely incredible what I
loved about this fight sequence is that
she actually used a force to push back
the enemy here I love how we get in more
use of the force and fight sequences and
judging by this martial arts scenes I
reckon we're going to see some really
cool lightsaber fights so I am actually
Keen for this show but let me know what
you guys think in the comment section
below and if you're new to the Channel
please consider subscribing thanks for
watching guys